all right so good morning and welcome to
the simons institute my name is peter
bartos i'm the associate director here
uh welcome to this
program on causality very excited to
have it running this semester
um
for those of you that haven't been here
before we're a collaborative research
institute in theoretical computer
science uh we've
been funded since 2012 by the simons
foundation
at least in part and just in the last
couple of years i've had that funding
renewed for another 10 years so
i'm very grateful to the simons
foundation we run these
semester length programs
typically two of them each each semester
they bring a whole lot of visitors to
the berkeley campus um this semester
we've got causality and learning and
games so something like 175 long-term
visitors here
uh including uh
16 research fellows
so
fantastic to have uh all that energy
here um a big thank you to the sloane
foundation and the nsf through uh fodzy
for their support of these programs this
semester
um the the bootcamp uh is a great start
to these these semester programs it's um
you know has a bit of an icebreaker role
um gets program participants
involved gets people on the same page uh
in in terms of the technical themes of
the of the program and also has a lot of
um archival value uh
you know the the videos of the the boot
camp talks are hugely popular on our um
youtube uh channel
um
okay a big big thank you to the
organizers of the causality bootcamp
we're also the program organisers uh
frederick eberhardt who is here uh
costas duskolakis malus mathus thomas
richardson
leonard shulman also here in caroline
hula's at the back over there um thanks
thanks to all of those folks for putting
together a great program for this week
uh so uh frederick will say a few words
about the
the themes of the boot camp in a moment
but let me let me mention some logistics
first
um
uh you know you're all wearing masks
we're required to wear them in the
building there's no food or drinks in
the building they're all
kept outside
you've discovered the
food and drinks no doubt we have that at
the breaks and uh
except for lunch so lunch times you're
on your own lots of options
uh around campus and and off campus um
if you'd like to leave things in lockers
when you go to lunch
there are lockers on the far side of the
building at this level
with a with a pin code pretty convenient
um there's wi-fi access now that you've
discovered that cal visitor and eduroam
if uh if you have that
and all of our talks are live streamed
and archived on youtube and on our
website uh and and also uh accessible
via zoom so
so people can ask questions online um
our videographer is omid farr in the
booth
the boot back here he's gonna be helping
with uh speakers connecting computers
providing microphones and so on
um and and also uh a big thank you to
uh ashley hassan our events coordinator
who's managed the organization
of the boot camp here if you have
questions please ask ashley thanks
ashley
[Applause]
all right i'll head over to frederick
thank you
welcome everyone i'm fredrick eberhardt
i'm one of the organizers of the
causality program this term on behalf of
all the organizers welcome to this
program
i'm very excited to see this many people
here in person two years ago when
peter and i were trying to think through
how to do this sort of thing
how to build this program i was sure
that we would be safely past the
pandemic well uh here we are still
uh working through it um i still hope
that we're going to have a lot of
opportunity to interact in person even
under these conditions so i'm really
glad to see everyone here i hope it will
work out this way
for the boot camp i'm very excited to
have four speakers uh over the week here
we're doing it a little different than
previous bootcamps have done it in that
we've decided that we're going to let
each speaker go for a whole day
basically meaning of course four hours
over spread over the day not in one one
go all the way through but the idea is
to really allow one speaker to develop a
little bit of theory more thoroughly
rather than just have a one-hour talk on
something specific uh to their interest
the other part is that the boot camp is
really there as an introduction to the
topic it's not the caffeine edge
research or anything like that it's it's
an uh attempt to get us all on the same
page to build some background together
and so many of you might have very
advanced background on this already uh
others of you will be completely new to
this so the boot camp is supposed to get
us onto the same page by giving a kind
of introduction
given that the simon's institute is an
institute for theoretical computer
science our thought was also to really
integrate uh
people from that sort of community into
work and causality and so i'm delighted
that spencer gordon who's
uh a phd student in theoretical computer
science is giving the first uh um
presentation today or is giving the
first day that will i hope or at least
that was the intention allow us to start
looking at the causality work from that
perspective i think and see how people
from theoretical computer science might
work their way into this sort of
material the following days we're
looking at causal discovery tomorrow
with dan milinski who i think is
somewhere here as well
and
then thomas richardson will talk about
potential outcomes on
thursday and on friday chandler squires
is going to talk about experimental
design
of course that's not all of causality we
have we have to choose and we have to
select we have to decide on what sort of
topics we're going to cover it's going
to be a biased introduction to causality
but uh we only had four days and we
thought that over those four days we
want to develop something uh real on
each day in any case let's get started
uh please welcome spencer gordon he's a
phd student at caltech working with
leonard schulman and he'll do the first
day on introduction to causal graphical
models spencer thanks
okay uh can everyone hear me
great uh
hi welcome to the
causality bootcamp first day i'm going
to be talking about causal graphical
models uh
the first thing to mention is there's a
handout
to accompany this talk with
everything i'm going to say in a lot
more detail
it's available at that url
feel free to follow along
but uh hopefully
i should be more interesting than
reading the handout
we'll see
um okay so
the
uh let's get started
um so
here's the table of contents uh we're
gonna start with an introduction and
then spend a lot of time talking about
bayesian networks and then finally turn
to causal
uh inference specific stuff uh later in
the day
mostly after lunch
um
i'll have a little bit more to say about
this after an introduction but um
let's
set up the sorts of things we're
interested in
so
first of all we're going to take the
viewpoint that all
causal
all causality is probabilistic take
something that's kind of like the
canonical
uh
sort of
causal statement that um
people would agree with um
all over the world
smoking causes lung cancer everyone
agrees but of course this is not a
deterministic fact you know there's no
set amount of cigarettes where if you
smoke this many cigarettes for this long
you're guaranteed to get lung cancer
the best you can say is that
you know a certain amount of smoking has
some likelihood of causing lung cancer
or increases the probability that you're
gonna get lung cancer or something like
that so we're gonna
treat causality as
inherently probabilistic uh
even if only because we don't have
enough information to
say something deterministic um
so yeah we'll use probabilities to
capture uncertainty and indeterminacy
and
in particular we're going to be
interested in what are called
probabilistic causal models this is
um
a pretty nice clean framework for
thinking about causality
uh we're going to do a bunch of
reasoning in that setting
um but we're mostly going to prove
things about
uh
bayesian networks in particular bayesian
networks with a causal interpretation
these are like the shadows of the
probabilistic causal model this is kind
of a representation of the limited
information you get
because you don't know everything in the
probable in the probabilistic causal
model um
okay so what is a probabilistic causal
model it is a tuple of four things first
we have a set of
background random variables u
and
these are
exogenous random variables we can't
observe them
we can't manipulate them they're just
out there this is
the only source of randomness in our
model
we're going to have a set of observable
variables
um this is what we're going to be uh
interested in understanding cause and
effect in we're not gonna
uh be able to say anything about
these uh background random variables u
and we're going to think of each of
these observable variables as taking on
a value by a deterministic function
of some of the other
observable random variables and some of
the background random variables
so our model also contains a collection
of functions one for each observable
that takes
some of the random some of the u
variables and some of the other
observables and produces the value for
x i
and then to fully specify the model we
need a joint distribution over the
hidden random variables the um
and so once i've
told you the distribution over u and
i've given you the functions that
compute all the x's as
uh based on the values of prior x's and
and the u then you get a distribution on
the observable random variables
um and you should think of
uh
you you should think of this
distribution p of v as being the only
thing you'd actually get access to and
um
in a
well
i'll have more to say about this later
so how do you compute this
you can just uh
for each value of u compute the
uh or
you can once i specify an assignment all
the u then i can just run through and
compute all the x's
um
so i can compute the joint distribution
over all the observables by
marginalizing out the u
let's make this more concrete with an
example
um okay so
the details of this example are not
important the point is just to get a
flavor of what these sorts of models
look like but uh for the sake of
concreteness let's say we have five
hidden random variables u1 through u5
we'll have five observable variables x1
through x5
i'll give the the functions uh that
determine the values of the x's below
um but
i want to specify the distribution over
the hidden random variables so i'll say
that all the ui are independent
um
and u1 is going to be uniform over
the seasons winter spring summer or fall
the other uis are just going to be
take on values negative one zero one
um
and
they'll represent a system kind of
boring system in which
we have variables for the season whether
it's raining or not whether the
sprinklers on or off whether
uh the sidewalk is wet and whether the
sidewalk is slippery and so you could
imagine that
once i
uh
tell you the season i can determine
whether
or there's some distribution on whether
it's raining that's determined just by
the season
so maybe if it's winter or fall then
it's more likely to be raining and i can
use this u2 variable which has some
distribution that
i didn't write down because the details
again are not important
to you know change the probability of
rain
it's just some independent way of
manipulating
the rain random variable and then i have
a sprinkler and maybe i only put the
sprinkler on
in the summer or the spring but
you know maybe u3 equaling one
that corresponds to
well maybe you
yeah there's a typo here
anyway uh
the point is you can
compute the values
of each of these x's by looking at the
values of the prior x's and some subset
of the random variables
so this is not particularly easy to
understand
and
that's why
we like to look at graphs
so we can represent a system like this
with a graph the induced graph of the
model
and
the graph is constructed as follows
you have a vertex for each of your
observable random variables and you have
an edge
x to y if the function that computes y
takes x as an input
and so
in this case
the
rain random variable is determined only
by the season and then some of the
hidden variables
the sprinkler is only determined by the
season and some of the hidden random
variables
but you know the sprinkler doesn't take
as input any of the variables below and
rain doesn't take the sprinkler's input
sprinkler doesn't take green as input
so
one thing to get out of the way is
in the definition i gave i forced these
graphs to be acyclic because i said x i
could only depend on x one through x i
minus one
in general you could
imagine relaxing that restriction and
there are reasons you might be
interested in that but throughout today
we're only going to be interested in
these acyclic probabilistic causal
models
and what about confounders so
none of the u variables are represented
on this in this diagram
um
and so what happens if i have a single
background or a random variable that
affects multiple observables
well i need to then i
reserve that information in this diagram
and so i add a
bi-directed edge so if there's
if f x and f y both take some u variable
as an argument we'll add an edge to this
diagram which will draw this dashed line
with two arrowheads
but it just mean which is just shorthand
for
the existence of some other vertex that
happens to be hidden which
is used to determine both x and y
uh okay another thing to note is
um without confounders
the distribution induced by
describing distribution over the uh
hidden variables
factors according to this graph by which
i mean
you can compute the or you can write the
joint distribution as the product of a
bunch of terms
conditional probability distributions
where each term corresponds to some
variable
conditioned on its parents
so this is going to be very important
and what follows and i'll
explain the relationship in more detail
later but
it's worth noting right now that
once you have this graph you also get
this nice representation
um so why are these called causal models
um
because you can represent uh
interventions in
these graphs and ask causal questions so
what would it mean to sorry i said you
can represent interventions in these
models and ask causal questions
so what would an intervention uh look
like well
uh imagine
this very boring system again uh i could
i might want to ask like what happens if
i
turn the sprinkler on or off what does
that do to whether the sidewalk is wet
or slippery
so and the way that we're going to model
that sort of question is
asking that question is like asking what
happens if i change the mechanism by
which the sprinkler
is on or off is determined if i change
that mechanism to a mechanism a new
mechanism that's just a constant
so
if i want to model the intervention of
turning the sprinkler off i basically
rip out the equation that determines x3
as a function of x2 x1 and some random
variables and i just replace it with the
constant
off
and so once i do that
that changes the
graph corresponding to this model and
this changes the distribution
over the observable random variables
and
we're going to write
p
sub x of v for the distribution we get
when we intervene
and set
some random variable x to the value
little x
so
one convention that i should note early
on is
we're going to use capital letters for
random variables and lowercase letters
for
assignments to those random variables
uh
it's going to be a little bit this
convention is going to fall apart a
little bit but hopefully it should be
mostly clear and in general if you see
an uppercase letter it's a random
variable a lowercase letter is the
corresponding is an assignment to that
random variable
so
let's look at the graph that we get when
we do this intervention
so we've forced the sprinkler to be off
uh
in the induced graph
we've replaced
the function f x 3
with a new function that doesn't depend
on x1 so we've deleted the edge
from x1 to x3
and what does this do to the joint
distribution
well now
if i look at some assignment to all the
variables
that is consistent with the intervention
in particular that means in which x3 is
set to off
well we can compute the probability of
that as follows
by using the
factorization that corresponds to this
graph
so we'll have a term for x1 and then a
term for x2 given x1
and then we won't have a term for x3
because
that's trivially set to off
and then in all the terms that depend on
x3 we won't plug in an arbitrary value
of x3 we'll just plug in the fixed value
of x3 at all
i should have said this earlier but
please stop me if you have questions
frederick will make sure that they don't
take up too much time so don't worry
about that when asking questions
yeah
[Music]
yeah so for those listening uh elsewhere
the question was
when i say that the induced graph
changes when i do an intervention
the only thing that changes is going to
be
the edges into the variables that i
intervened on so in general we'll think
of interventions you can apply them to
multiple variables at the same time
and then any edges into any of those
variables will get deleted but but yeah
that that's the only sort of change that
an intervention will cause
um
okay and so another thing to note is
um
we can compute this interventional
distribution
uh in this case from the observed
distribution alone
right this factorization doesn't contain
any terms that explicitly refer to you
so if we had the observed distribution
alone and the factorization for the
observed distribution
then uh we could compute this
interventional distribution
this will not always be the case
so let's look at the simplest sort of
example in which this is not the case
so here we have two observables x and y
and some
uh u
that is the
upon which both x and y depend
um so again just to remind you
this picture is exactly the same thing
as this picture
and
so how would we write the interventional
distribution in this case
well we'd get it by
taking the joint distribution
and then marginalizing out u
but uh
when we do that we'll have
[Music]
this term but we'll have two terms that
explicitly refer to you
um and so if we don't have access to the
distribution over u
we can't compute this
um
and so again the reason that we get this
expression is that after we do the
intervention
the induced graph is going to be of this
form we've deleted the u to x edge since
u no longer influences x we fixed x
but u still influences y and so
we still want it we still have to
compute
y given x and um
[Music]
so again the the
point i'm
the point the key point to take away
from this example is
knowing the distribution over the
observed variables alone is not
sufficient to compute the interventional
distribution
uh let's look at a slightly modified
example
so you might think that this example uh
similar we have a variable u that talks
to both x and y
uh can we compute the
distribution on y
when we interview being on x
uh
maybe maybe not
um
so it turns out in this case
unlike the previous case
we can compute
the interventional distribution
that we get when we intervene on x and
in particular we compute the
distribution on y
in the modified
when we intervene on x
and we can do this without knowing the
distribution of our hidden random
variables
so how would we do this well
we would
uh
look at the joint distribution
over it after post intervention on y z
and u
we marginalize out z and u
and it turns out with some algebra um
that you can eventually get this to a
form that doesn't depend on you
so in particular we have this p of z
given x term doesn't
uh depend on u we can pull it outside
the summation
and then uh by the law of total
probability these two terms will combine
and we'll get rid of the the u here so
it turns out the final interventional
distribution is just
the product of these two terms of x
given
z given x and then of y given z
um
so this may be kind of surprising maybe
not
um
so
in
okay
yes sorry i
yeah thank you i dropped
the summation over z i do need the
summation over z here okay my goal is to
marginalize that z
um
yeah
sorry about that
um
okay so another thing to note is
if you have an expression of
this form that is an expression that
doesn't refer to you
um and you've computed it via
correct
manipulations of probabilities
you've also you also have a proof that
the observational distribution
determine uniquely determines the
interventional distribution in any
causal model that induces that graph
and in this case we say that the
interventional distribution is
identifiable
um i'll go into more detail into this
and define this a little more precisely
later but uh
for now
identifiability means observational
distribution is sufficient to determine
the interventional distribution
um
so
in terms of
the graph the the difference is
the presence of this intermediate
variable z
which does not depend on you
um
as for why this allows you to compute
the interventional distribution um
i'll have a answer in the afternoon but
a lot of today will be spent in
developing the theory that we need to be
able to
prove that
we can compute this interventional
distribution and we can't in the prior
example
um
so this is sort of the motivating
question for today how can you
distinguish between these two cases
and
if i give you a situation where the
interventional distribution is
identifiable can you give me
the formula
that expresses it as a function of the
observational distribution yeah
um
okay so the question was
uh
well
correct me if i'm
phrasing this incorrectly but
the question
one way looking at the question is what
if the function that realized z is
uh from x was the identity map then
doesn't this reduce
to uh the previous model
and the answer is
um
yes in the sense that uh
you can realize any distribution
consistent with the
or
you could any distribution that was
consistent with the previous model could
exist in this model but you get this
additional information you get to
observe this z
in this model which is you know is not
depend which you know is not determined
by you or at least does not directly is
not directly influenced by you so that's
the additional
information you get in this model that
allows you to
uh
do more
sorry to jump ahead but um
in this graph there's a back door right
next to why
so shouldn't this just be unidentifiable
like we can't you know what i mean if
you can't close this back door
through you then there's no way to
identify the effect of x on y
and similarly like in the previous
example where it's the x directly
affecting y
in a concrete scenario you can imagine
just identifying some mediating variable
z
inserting it and then you'd always be
able to
identify the inner effect of x on y
um
so i i guess and mathematically like is
it this term p z given x that should not
be able to come out of the sum
because we're summing over z
so
your
first thing again there should be a
summation over z here
yes so this is just incorrect as written
imagine a
sigma
z
outside of this
um
i i don't know if like
this is meant to you're trying to relate
this to like instrumental variables or
something but
like the graph is slightly different in
that case like the u would point to z
and x would be the instrument but yeah
so i
i'm not sure i have
enough knowledge of
uh
instrumental variables to say anything
intelligent about that um so the only
difference with that is that the graph
would have you pointing to z and not to
x and then x is free of u
but because x is not free of u here and
there's this kind of
like
so the
concern for those listening is that it
shouldn't be possible to identify this
effect because of this
path between
uh from x to y and via u
um
i claim that this is a proof that it is
identifiable modulo the incorrect
lack of summation
so
if
so the question is whether or not you
believe this group uh
let me try to address your question
later today uh if
this isn't
i'm not sure i have all that much to say
about it without developing some more
theory um
spencer can you hear me
yes
uh this is this is thomas reason i i
just have a quick question about your
last simplification
when you go from the sum over u to p of
u p of y given z and u
because
u is not independent of z so it's not
clear to me how you're
able to do that last step because u is
only independent of z after intervention
not in the original observed
distribution so i i don't think that
last simplification is right
even with the sum over z even with the
sum of a z added i still think that last
simplification
from the second last line to the last
line i don't think those two expressions
are equal
uh
i believe they are just by the law of
total probability if i sum over all
values of u
i should be able to eliminate the u
uh you
uh
let me
assume
let me i would need to write this down
to to
verify this let me
check things over later and get back to
you uh
if i'm convinced you're correct
uh for the sake of okay
i'm going to move on i just want to be
clear that the identifying expression
you've got there is not this is the
front door model and that is not the
identifying expression for the front
door model even with the sun over set so
just want to be clear about it okay at
some point later i will replace this
with a corrected slide
that uh hopefully we'll all be able to
agree is in fact correct
let me move on to the time being and
i'll
stop for questions in a bit um
okay
so
here's the big picture for today
um there exists an algorithm that takes
a graph induced by a causal model a
distribution over the observable
variables for that model and our target
intervention
we want to intervene on variables x
and look at the effect on variables y
and it will return a formula for the
interventional distribution on y
when you intervene on x if it's
identifiable from the observables and if
it's not it will return a proof that
it's not identifiable
so our goal for uh today is to get to
the
um to be able to understand this result
uh not in full detail but at least the
basic outline of the result um
i should note that this is not the only
uh algorithm for solving this problem
there are other algorithms i chose this
one because the one i understand best
and it's relatively simple
as far as these things go
um okay so the agenda
we want to understand the relationship
between dags and distributions that
factor over those dags
then we're gonna address the question
when do two dags induce the same
or correspond to the same set of
possible distributions
um
then we're going to look at what
conditional independencies are implied
by a dag
and then we'll go into the do calculus
which is a set of rules for manipulating
interventional distributions
and then finally we'll look at the
schpitzer patrol id algorithm
um
sorry i think there was a question over
there yes yeah
so
just because i'm beginner in that stuff
i would like to understand something if
you give me a graph can you every can
you give me a very simple graph and
explain why there are at least two
causal different models because i
remember in your in your phrase that you
say
about the
identifiability that that means that for
any causal model that can be used by
this graph so can you give me a graph
and two causal models that are used by
this graph yeah
simply sure what do yeah so the question
is like
in the case where something's not
identifiable like what does that look
like so
let me go back to the
example that i claimed was not
identifiable so
here's a causal model in which
or here there are two causal models
in which
the observable distributions are the
same
and the interventional distributions are
different so imagine
first that u is uniform between 0 and 1
and then x it just takes on the same
value as u and then y just takes on the
same value as you
so here you see that x equals y with
probability one
um and yet
intervening on x and setting x to 1 or 0
has no impact whatsoever on y
because y just gets its value based on u
so it's a little bit it's cheating in
the sense that y actually doesn't depend
on x
in some sense
but uh it's still consistent with the
edges in this graph
so the other model is
u doesn't do anything x is just uh or
sorry u is uniformly zero or one and
then u doesn't actually influence y
directly y just takes on
x just takes on the value that u does
and then y just takes on the value that
x does
so in that model intervening on x would
cause y to
whatever you set x to y will take on
that value with probability one
so in one model intervening on x does
nothing in the other model intervening
on x deterministically sets wide equal
to x
excellent
now my question is the following in your
last
example where you say y equals actually
x and x just gets the value by you
why that's
why there is a task line between u and y
because it is not clear that they have
in
do you see what i am saying but um i
don't let me
come let me come back to it later uh if
you saw the question i'm a little bit
worried about time
maybe just to say that edges allow
influence they don't require it okay
yeah okay so sorry
the concern was
in one in one of the two models i've
described u doesn't actually do anything
to y
that's okay because
yeah the edge just means i have a
function like that y can be expressed as
a function of x and u
and one function of x and u is the
function that just ignores you
it is cheating in the sense that yeah
you you might want an example in which
you still somehow
is in
is used in the function
um
but uh
this is that would be allowable under
this uh
yeah that is consistent with everything
i've described to
not actually
have a variable depend on all the
values that the function determining it
takes as arguments it can just ignore
arguments that's fine
just to clarify you're using sums
everywhere and all your examples are
discrete this this works entirely fine
with continuous variables right yeah so
the question was uh
i'm using zones everywhere and all my
examples are discrete does this work for
continuous variables and yes with some
slight modifications
but basically everything just carries
through with continuous variables
um
okay uh so that was
the big picture our goal is to work up
to the schvitzer pearl id algorithm and
we're gonna have to do a whole bunch of
stuff to get there and uh the first
thing we're going to do is look at
bayesian networks
okay
so
sorry there are a couple of
preliminaries
um
so
let's just uh
remind ourselves of the definition of
conditional independence
so we say that two random variables are
independent condition on z for all
assignments to
the random variables so we'll use
d
sub random variable for the domain of
the random variable for discrete random
variables just the support
um so for all values that x can take on
y can take on and z can take on
the probability of x given y and z
should be equal to the probability of x
given z whenever y of the joint is
whenever the probability of y and z
is nonzero
alternatively
uh we can express the condition as
follows the probability of x and y given
z
should be factorable into a term
probability of x given z times the
probability of y given z
and if this is the case we write that x
and y are well we write this expression
with a double turn style
and we pronounce this x and y are
conditionally independent given z in the
distribution p
um
this subscript p
is quite important it looks
at the moment like it's superfluous
uh we'll often be dealing with
multiple distributions at a time and
it'll be important to distinguish
conditional independence in one
distribution from conditional attendance
in a different distribution
we'll also have a
modified piece of notation
uh corresponding to graphs so
the only thing i
want you to
take away from
this point is just pay attention to the
subscript
okay
and some concepts
from
graph theory that we're going to need
so this is a
dag a directed acyclic graph
[Music]
we're going to often talk about directed
paths in a dag so directed path is a
sequence of distinct vertices
uh each of
each consecutive pair of vertices in it
is adjacent via an edge that points at
via edges that all point in the same
direction
so this is an example a to b to e to f
to g it's a directed path
um and we'll use this notation
occasionally
uh
as a the proposition that there exists a
directed path between a and g
or to refer to a
we'll write something on top of the
arrow to refer to a specific directed
path between angie
so
the next notion we'll need is a trail
so a trail in a directed graph
for our purposes will be a sequence of
distinct vertices that are adjacent
via edges
in either direction
so here we take an edge
from d to b
where the edge points towards d
and then we take an edge from b to e
where the edge points away from d and
when you lay it out like this
um so this is an example of a trail
and we'll use this funny notation for
the proposition
that there exists trail between d and c
in a given graph
it's a squiggly line with two circles on
the end
this is the circles on the end are
intended to indicate that we don't know
the orientation of the edges
in the trail
um okay so the next concept we'll need
is that of parents so
appearance of a vertex or a set of
vertices is just all the
the vertices in
for which there's a
edge into
the set
so the parents of f
are e and c because e and c have a
direct edge into f
and then ancestors the ancestors is the
closure
of uh the parent relationship it's all
the things you can get by taking parents
of parents of parents of parents
any number of times including zero times
so it's everything
uh
the ancestors of a set is just all the
vertices for which there's a directed
edge or directed path
into the set
so there's a directed path from a to f
in this graph so a is an ancestor of f
there's a directed path of length zero
from f to f so f is its own ancestor
and then
similarly we have children and
descendants
and again descendants contain
the set of descendants of a set
include the set itself
so another concept that will be
important is that of an upward closed
set
so this is also known as an ancestral
set elsewhere
it's just a set of vertices in a dag
that contains its own ancestors
so if i look at the ancestors of
anything in a b c or d
it's also
the ancestors of
a b c and d are just a b c and d
themselves so this is an ancestral or
upward closed set
i'll try to be consistent and talk about
upwards closed
sets but i may slip up and talk about
ancestral sets at some point but
and finally we'll need to talk about
induced subgraphs so the induced
subgraph
uh so if i have a if i have a graph g
and some subset of the vertices the
induced sub graph
on those on that vertex set is just
the graph i get
uh
when i remove all the vertices outside
the set
and remove all the edges
outside the set and just keep the
vertices in the set and all the edges
between them
um
okay
an arrow from b to
b to f
uh
from b to f yeah
i don't think so there has never been an
arrow
for the new sub graph
so i don't add
any edges that are not present in the
original graph
it's just the restriction of the
original graph two things
uh two two edges and vertices
exclusively contained within this set
um there could be other errors but i
don't think so
um okay so now we come to bayesian
networks
so what is a bayesian network it's a dag
along with a distribution on that dag
that factors according to that dag by
which i mean
the joint distribution over all the
vertices on that dag can be written as
the product
of
terms of the form probability of some x
given its parents
so we're going to take this to be the
definition of the base of a bayesian
network and we're going to provide some
alternative characterizations
in a minute um
so
we'll often be interested in
the question of is a given distribution
can it be factored according to
a graph and
if it can by which i mean its
factorization
looks like this or it has a it can be
factored like this then we'll say that
uh the distribution is compatible with
the graph g or occasionally we'll say p
is markov relative to the graph g
i tend to prefer the compatibility uh
terminology
but i may
at some point just switch to the other
for no particular reason
um
and we'll write
uh
mathcal
pfg for the set of distributions
consistent or compatible with g
um okay so let's
prove something pretty easy
so if i have an upwards closed set and a
distribution that's compatible with g
then
we can write the joint distribution over
the set
s
as
or we can express that by
writing the joint distribution over
everything and marginalizing out
um the vertices not an s
and then we're left with a product of
the terms corresponding to the vertices
in s
and so we get that the joint
distribution over s is compatible with
the graph
the the induced subgraph on s
and
another
uh result in this vein
the conditional distribution on
everything but s given s
is compatible with
the graph
the induced sub graph on everything but
s
so
this is
an example of how you can
get some pretty powerful conclusions
from just this factorization alone
um
uh
let's turn to some alternative
characterizations which we'll prove
which are often more useful
okay
so
um
so the first characterization that we'll
want to prove is the following
p is compatible with the graph g if in
any topological ordering
of the vertices x1 through xn
each xi is independent of its
predecessors
given its appearance
so another way of writing that is
well
using the notation that i introduced
already
this is the same thing as
x i is conditionally independent of
x one
given
so let's try and prove this
characterization
um
so let's first start with the forward
direction
so assume p is compatible with g
um then
fix some topological ordering on the
vertices
[Music]
so now
we can look at the joint distribution
over
x1
through
xi
and the joint distribution of
x1
through
xi minus 1.
now the first in a topological ordering
the first i vertices are an upward
closed set
there are no predecessors to those
vertices
that are not included in this set
um so this is just
the product of
hey at most
i
and then this is just the product
sorry this should be an xj
uh
so the joint distribution over the first
i vertices is just the product
of the terms corresponding to the first
i vertices the joint distribution over
the first i minus 1 is the product of
the first time minus 1. and so the
conditional probability
of x i given
x 1 through x i minus 1
is just the ratio
of
this term over this term and so all the
terms in these two products are going to
cancel out except for the term
corresponding to
e of
x i given parents
of x i
and so by the first characterization of
conditional probability
this is a proof that
if p is compatible with g then in any
topological ordering
each xi is independent of its
predecessors given its parents
yes um could you remind me what a
topological ordering is and that depends
on the graph
g yeah
so i probably should have defined that
explicitly so what is a topological
ordering
um
a topological ordering of a graph
of the vertices in a graph
is just some
ordering of the vertices some
enumeration of the the vertices in the
graph that is consistent with the
predecessor relationship so
that means
uh
no vertex should appear
uh
after any of its predecessors
um and that's pretty much
the only constraint sorry but after its
ancestors
um
yeah please
do stop me if i've
failed to define anything else important
um
okay so what about the other direction
if uh
p is or sorry if in any topological
ordering each xi is independent of its
predecessors given as parents
uh how do we know that p is compatible
with g
um well just
write out the joint distribution using
the chain rule so
sorry
i just assumed what i intended to prove
so i can do this for any joint
distribution
and then
the assumption that each xi is
independent of its predecessors given
its parents
means that i can
replace each of these terms
with um
e of x j
given the appearance of x j
so
that
suffices to prove this ordered markov
condition one thing to note is we didn't
actually need
the full strength of in any topological
ordering
uh
each xi is independent of its
predecessors it's sufficient to know
that there's one topological ordering
in which that's the case and then we can
conclude that p is compatible with g
is there a question
is
question
show what would be statistically true if
as fast as the correct
um
the question is what's the point of this
condition uh
like you should observe this in your
data
i'm not sure i can
give you an explanation outside of just
developing the theory here it turns out
to be useful
uh sometimes to
explicitly construct a distribution
that
by giving a topological ordering and
then
uh
showing
that each xi is independent of its
predecessors given his parents and then
you get the p is compatible with g uh
yeah my explanation is only the only
answer i have for why this is useful
uh
at the moment is we're going to use it
in subsequent proofs
um
yeah
so another characterization um
the parental markov condition
so it's also the case that p is
compatible with g if and only if each x
is independent of its non-descendants
given its parents
so i won't bother to write anything down
because it's very straightforward so
how do we prove this well
let's say p is compatible with g
then we can appeal to the ordered markov
condition
and
uh
pick a topological order in which all of
x's non-descendants
come before x
and then
just
apply the conclusion here
x is and to get that x is independent of
its non-descendants given its parents
and for the other direction if
each x is independent of its
non-descendants
then
[Music]
fix some topological order
and then the non-descendants of
x include all of its predecessors so
it's an immediate consequence of this um
sorry that was a bit brief but
uh it's a worthwhile exercise to do it
in more detail if you haven't seen this
before
um
so i think we're going to finish this
segment
with a nice lemma that uh
will be used quite a bit later
which is
the following
so
uh the way i like to think about it is
we if we're given it well
i'll just read it and then i'll
interpret it
so
fix some graph and three sets x y and z
and if all the common ancestors
of x and y
are contained within z
then
and the ancestors of z
are contained within z so this is
exactly
the definition of upwards closed
then
x and y are conditionally independent
given z
um
in any distribution p compatible with
that graph
so the picture you want to have in mind
is
here's our graph and the up to down
direction will roughly correspond to
uh
the predecessor or the parent child
relationship so here's our set x
here's our set y
and
the ancestors of x maybe it looks like
this the ancestors of y maybe it looks
like this
and z is sunset
that's closed under ancestor under the
ancestral relationship that includes all
the common ancestors of x and y
then conditioning
on z
eliminates any dependence between x and
y
and so x and y are conditionally
independent given z
um
so let's
prove this
so we're going to use this uh little
lemma that for this observation that i
stated and didn't prove that
the distribution
p of v
minus
z given
z
is compatible with
g
of
the induced subgraph on v
minus z
given z
so under this system or assuming this
observation
we can write uh
well
we'll use this observation along with
the following definition so
let
x prime be the ancestors
of x minus z
let y prime
be
the ancestors
of y
minus c
so that is
x prime is this set
y prime is
this set
um
so
in the graph the induced subgraph on
v minus z
induced by
uh conditioning
on
sorry this
notation is incorrect but i meant to
write the following
so the observation gives us that
the distribution on the remaining
vertices given z is compatible with the
induced subgraph on the remaining
vertices
now in this induced sub graph
x prime and y prime are
upwards closed
and in particular their union is upwards
closed
so i can write
the prop the
distribution
on x prime
and y prime
given z
using
this compatibility as the product
over
uh
i need another variable name
w in
x prime
union
y prime
sorry is this
not is this visible or is it too low
uh it's about as low as you can go i
think okay
um
i'm blocking everything with this
picture
um
[Music]
okay so
let me
transcribe this formula a little bit
higher up
so
i think there's another voice about mine
um
i won't need much more space for for
right now i'll figure something else out
for later but uh
the joint distribution on x prime and y
prime given z
can be written as the product
of terms
uh
each of which is the form some variable
given its parents
just
containing variables
in this set
so
so
in
sorry
i'm
decomposing this distribution into terms
uh
for just x prime and y prime
and i'm using this observation that
their union is upwards closed
so the joint distribution on x prime and
y prime in this conditional
distribution
here
factors as such
and then if i just pull apart
the terms corresponding to x prime and
the terms corresponding to y prime
i get that
this is equal to probability of x prime
given z
times the probability of y prime
given z
um
and uh
then i can just marginalize out
by
the
variables in x prime or y prime
that are not in x or y
right so the thing
i wanted to show was
that
the joint distribution over x and y
given z
is equal to
the probability of x given z times the
probability of y given z
which is implied
by
this uh larger conditional independence
um
okay so
uh
hopefully
that wasn't
too
surprising but uh
we've now shown this nice slimmer which
we'll use i think in the next session
um
and this
much time
okay and i think that's it for right now
uh and i guess we'll continue after a
break
right so i guess we're reconvening that
um
i'll cover the bell
i see questions coming in from some chat
session on the screen
hey